still in decided presidential election
now the race between president trump and
former vice president joe biden
has slowed to a crawl votes in four key
states nevada
arizona georgia and pennsylvania are
still being counted
joe biden currently sitting 17 votes shy
of the 270 electoral votes needed to win
is leading in all four of those states
on friday biden jumped ahead of
president trump and pennsylvania thanks
in part to a strong showing in
philadelphia
supporters there filled the streets in
hopes of a victory that would put biden
over 270 electoral votes
meanwhile supporters of president trump
rallied outside a vote count location in
arizona the president needs victories in
arizona and all but one of those other
toss-up states to win another four years
in the white house
late last night biden addressed the
nation from wilmington delaware
nicole killian is covering the biden
campaign nicole good morning
good morning jeff former vice president
joe biden hopes to be able to address
the american people
again today but last night he made clear
he believes he's
well on his way to victory and has a
mandate to get to work
we're going to win this race former vice
president joe biden
addressing the nation last night just a
few votes shy of reaching the 270
electoral votes
needed to win the presidency we're on
track to
over 300 electoral votes electoral
college votes
and look at the national numbers we're
going to win this race with a clear
majority of the nation behind us
we've gotten over 74 million votes
let me repeat that 74 million votes
biden did not claim victory but his
remarks came at the end of a day that
began with him taking over the lead in
pennsylvania
and georgia blinked by his running mate
senator kamala harris
biden gave a preview of what his
administration's priorities would be
we have serious problems to deal with
from covet to the economy to racial
justice and climate change
we don't have any more time to waste and
he called for an
end to what he called partisan warfare
the purpose of our politics
the work of the nation isn't to fan the
flames of conflict
but to solve problems
before those remarks aides had planned
for
biden to deliver a prime time speech
but that was only if the race had been
called delaware senator chris coons told
reporters he thinks pennsylvania could
be called
as early as today which would be enough
to put the former vice president
over the top dana all right nicole thank
you we are all anxiously waiting